>> ♪ ♪
>> GET READY FOR ANARCHY IN
ATLANTA.
THUGS ARE CALLING FOR A NIGHT OF
RAGE AGAINST LAW ENFORCEMENT
TOMORROW AFTER POLICE SHOT AND
KILLED A MAN BECAUSE HE STARTED
SHOOTING AT A STATE TROOPER
WITHOUT WARNING.
POLICE SAY IT WAS IN
SELF-DEFENSE.
THE COPS RAIDED A ZONE SET UP TO
PROTEST A LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING CENTER.
THE CALL FOR VIOLENCE WAS POSTED
ON TWITTER BUT TAKEN DOWN.
IT CALLED FOR VIOLENCE TO BE
DONE TO THE POLICE AND THEIR
ALLIES.
GEORGIA COPS ARE NOT BACKING
DOWN TO THE THREATS.
>> ACTS SUCH AS ARSON AND
PHYSICAL ATTACKS ON MEMBERS OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE USE OF
EXPLOSIVES AND SETTING TRAPS
THAT COULD CAUSE GREAT BODY HARM
OR COULD MAIM ARE NOT ACT OF
PEACEFUL PROTEST.
THEY ARE CRIMINAL ACT THAT
DESTABILIZE COMMUNITIES AND
ENDANGER CITIZENS.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS IS GETTING
A LOT OF MEDIA COVERAGE, GREG
GUTFELD?
>> ALL WE HEAR ABOUT FROM THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA IS THIS
INVISIBLE WORLD OF WHITE
SUPREMACY.
ANTIFA IS OUT THERE DOING
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THEM.
THEY ARE OVERWHELMINGLY WHITE.
THEY ARE MISFITS.
THEY ARE MISERABLE.
INITIALLY THE MEDIA ELEVATED
THEM BECAUSE THEY AGREED WITH
THEM BECAUSE THEY WERE
ANTI-FASCISTS.
REMEMBER CNN?
IF ANYBODY ELSE SAID THIS, IT
WOULD BE HATE SPEECH.
A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
BUT THE WAY THE MEDIA LOOKS AT
THIS, THEY LEARNED NOTHING FROM
GEORGE FLOYD.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
DESTROY SOCIETY.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
TREATED DIFFERENTLY.
THE COPS GET MORE SUPPORT.
THE MEDIA BACKS OFF AND SAYS
LET'S NOT BET ON THE WRONG HORSE
THIS TIME.
THAT COST BILLION DOLLARS OF
DAMAGES AND DOZENS LIVES IN
RIOTS AND THOUSANDS OF LIVES
WITH A CRIME EPIDEMIC.
SUPPORT THE COPS.
>> IT'S A BIG STATEMENT TO CALL
FOR MASS VIOLENCE AGAINST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEIR ALLIES.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH EVERYBODY.
>> THEY WERE CAMPING OUT IN THE
PARK IN ATLANTA FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY ARE PROTESTING THE BUILDING
OF A POLICE TRAINING FACILITY
BECAUSE TRAINING POLICE IS BAD?
>> THEY WANT LESS TRAINING.
>> AND THE RESTED ANTIFA
TERRORIST 22 YEARS OLD SON OF
A MILLIONAIRE FROM MAINE.
SAILED ON A YACHT AND NOW LIVES
IN THE WOODS.
THEY ALLOWED THESE NUTS TO LIVE
IN THE WOODS FOR TOO LONG.
THINK ABOUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WITH HOMELESSNESS PROBLEMS.
LET THEN A WARNING WANT DON'T
ALLOW THESE NUTS TO LIVE OUT IN
THE WOODS LIKE THIS.
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
THERE ARE HOMELESS PROBLEMS
EVERYWHERE.
THIS IS A CHOICE.
THIS IS A RICH KID.
>> I WANT THEM TO LIVE IN THE
WOODS AWAY FROM ME!
MAYBE THEY WILL GET EATEN BY
BEARS.
>> THEY ARE NOT JUST CAMPING.
THEY ARE BUILDING TREE HOUSES
AND THROWING MOLATOV COCKTAILS
AT PEOPLE.
WHY?
>> THEY BELIEVE A NIGHT IT OF
RAGE IS APPROPRIATE.
THAT'S TOTAL ANARCHY.
WE BELIEVE THAT LAW AND ORDER OR
WE DON'T.
DON'T YOU NEED A PERMIT TO GO
INTO THESE PLACES?
IF I WANT TO CAMPOUT IN THE
WOODS OR YOU HAVE AN RV, YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A PERMIT.
OR ELSE IT'S TRESPASS.
GET THEM THE HELL OUT THERE WAS
AND LET THEM KNOW WHO IS RUNNING
THE PLACE.
>> WHY CAN'T JOE BIDEN CONDEMNED
THE TREE HOUSE ANTIFA?
>> THAT'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION.
>> JOE BIDEN HAS A LOT ON HIS
PLATE.
>> MOSTLY GELATIN.
>> JOE BIDEN HAS CONDEMNED
ANTIFA WHICH IS PEOPLE WHO HATE
WHITE SUPREMACY.
HE SAID WHAT CHRISTOPHER WRAY
SAID FROM THE FBI.
IT'S A LOOSE ORGANIZATION OF
PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT CENTRALIZED.
THEY ARE FROM ATLANTA TO
SEATTLE.
>> IT'S VERY LOOSE.
>> LIKE THE PROUD BOYS?
>> NO, THE PROUD BOYS IS QUITE
ORGANIZED.
ISN'T IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> IS THAT A TRICK?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> ALL VIOLENCE IS SAD.
WHO STUCK OUT TO ME IS THE
HORROR OF THIS POLICE OFFICERS
BEING SHOT.
THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE FRONT
AND HOW PEOPLE FEEL ABOUT IT ON
THE GROUND WANT THE POLICE ARE
POPULAR IF PLACES WITH HIGH
MINORITY POPULATIONS THAT WANT
MORE COPS ON THE STREET VERSUS
LESS.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IF YOU ARE TRESPASSING, THAT
SHOULD BE THE CHARGE.
IT'S LOUISVILLE IF SOMEONE HAS
A TENT OUT THEY ARREST YOU AND
TAKE YOU IN RIGHT AWAY.
THEY HAVE TO START DOING THAT IN
OTHER PLACES.
>> GOOD.
>> DIDN'T JOE BIDEN BAIL OUT
ANTIFA?
>> WHAT?
>> NO, KAMALA HARRIS.
>> IT'S